Functionally homogeneous architectures
can be characterized as follows.
Any node can process any type
of reques,t and can do any of
the processing actions that are required
in the end to end request processing.
Again, this resembles
the basic boss worker model.
The front end component is the boss,
responsible for
pushing requests onto the workers.
And, all the workers can perform all
of the required steps for a request.
The benefit of this is that
the front-end can be made
kept fairly simple.
It doesn't have to keep
track which one of the nodes
can perform which particular action,
or can service which types of request.
Instead, the front end can
simply in a round robin manner,
send requests onto
the next available node.
Or, the front end could be enhanced
in some simple way in which it keeps
some information regarding the CPU
loads, the CPU utilization,
on the other nodes in the system.
And then,
it can use that type of information to
direct requests onto the worker nodes.
This design doesn't mean that every
single one of the nodes has to store
all of the data, all of the state
that's needed for the internet service.
Instead, data may be somehow replicated,
or distributed across these nodes.
But, with the homogeneous design,
every single one of the nodes knows how
to get, how to access any type of
information that may be necessary for
the execution of the service.
One downside of this approach
is that there is little
opportunity to benefit from caching.
If the front end is simple,
and it just passes requests round
robin onto the other nodes.
It may not be able, and in fact, it will
not be able to explore opportunities
like, this particular node,
already serviced some state, and
therefore it's likely
present in its cache.
And, it will not need to perform
a remote access in order to access that
particular information.